when I'm in China live in Beijing or
Shanghai when I'm out here I have a home
in know they yeah I travel a lot like
pretty much every other month I'll be
flying like back and forth from Beijing
to LA it'd be a 11 hour flight from
Beijing to New York it'd be 15 hour
flight so pretty insane what's good GQ
is your boy Chris ooh and these are my
essentials well that's our chopstick so
in China everyone uses chopsticks and
when you're young God usually your
parents will teach you how to use a
chopstick I never learn how to use them
properly because this is a lesson to
everyone who was interested in learning
but this is the way he's supposed to use
it with the middle finger in between and
then kind of move it like this I just do
it kind of like like this just cheating
a little bit I can't be a lot of things
with chopsticks even eating like a
chicken wing I just stab it and just
start eating it I'm gonna use my hand
it's a lot cleaner I like it
there you go chopsticks all right
supreme boxers I love these it's so
comfortable and at the same time stylish
when you sag their pants a little bit
you know we hear pop so tasty the louis
supreme feels good there you go supreme
boxers essentially this little guy this
thing right here you wonder was or is
actually a doorknob so back in the days
in China a lot of doors would have these
type of door knobs on it and this is a
lion so it's like a gate keeper and then
you were not gonna do it with this
little guy there's probably only one in
the world and I got it from this
collector in China he was collecting
these necklaces at first he didn't want
to sell it to me eventually the guy was
like okay yeah I'll sell it to you
because you actually look good with them
and you're actually representing the
culture you might wonder why is not Roli
I have something with Bulgari and we
have a long term relationship and these
are two pieces I carry with me at all
times I have quite a big collection of
boob already watch and there's one that
I really wanted to ice it out I think I
look
nice because not a lot of people I saw a
blue Garvey watch so next time when I
come back you guys would see the iced
out version get ready they might be
women's but you know if it lists could
you and you're gonna rock with it as an
artist you know gotta have these but
this is something special still I rise
why is that so I just have a tattoo all
my fans know it's right here these are
one-of-a-kind there's only one in the
world I also have these for different
purposes did you say check now mix on
the record you want to check on
different headphones at by this time I
haven't allowed to be out so I gotta say
like on tours will be on my playlist for
sure my birthday is actually in November
November 6 and there's a song called
November rain it's one of my favorite
songs from the album I hope it will be
the biggest song in November so let's
just say November rain for sure
the top one all I play this right now at
the moment and also I've been just
checking out a lot of dope artists on
black you know he's a new album
Astroworld Travis Scott you know the old
guy so by this time you guys should
already know I love Sabrina gotta have
an apple with me make music make beats
but just watch my ten essential video
when it comes out you know it's just a
map again I hope you guys all have one
wanna make music because these are good
on to the next
and China these are very very popular
you know I can get away from people that
might recognize me but with this they
might not recognize me so this is very
essential for me in China
90% of celebrities in China they all
have these these are just very basic but
I custom-made one where on the
coordinate is a low dragon when you're
rocking the right way they become like a
little fashion item I'm not really a
like a huge fan of like sunglass but I
like glasses where like they have color
and adds that little extra swag and I
like people to see my eyes you know on
stage like I feel like when you're
performing they always want that eye
contact
so what's also dope about these is if
you check out my album cover right here
I'm wearing the same ones this is
essential for me I need this a silo
extra starts away and it's really useful
like you know you put your phones
whatever cigarette ass for anything I
can even sometimes fit like like small
headphones and maybe I've wanted to
watch inside I don't even know if we can
buy these anymore that maybe they start
making them but these are definitely
nice ones I mean they're hot they're
Harper reason I last up
check it out first of all this is my
Chinese name in the back is alerted to
my song that's on the album called tmv
it's a Chinese song lui all Jamali
and means don't judge people by first
sight first of all and when you want to
see their full potential you got to give
them time and then you'll know if they
really got like something to show you
this is a special one for me because
right here this is my my fan club like
what my fans are called but this is
actually a gift for my fans my fans and
was funny as my Chinese name is is also
spelled fa n all comes together and this
is it this is a dopey they're super
practical and they got that you know
when you close in an opening like this
got that swag so it's around Oh before I
go I gotta say make sure y'all check out
the new album thanks so much and I hope
you guys like my 10